ברוכים הבאים חזרה למחשוב קוונטי בפועל אני המנחה שלכם Olivia Lanes בפעם הקודמת עברנו על דוגמה של
גישה של מחשוב קוונטי לבעיית אופטימיזציה שנקראת Max Cut באמצעות הניסוח של QUBO עברנו
לעומק יחסי אבל זו הייתה רק דוגמה אחת של גישה אחת היום אנחנו הולכים לדבר על יישומים בטווח הקרוב
בצורה רחבה יותר ולפתח את האינטואיציה שלנו לגבי סוגים שונים של בעיות שאנחנו מצפים למצוא פתרונות קוונטיים שימושיים
עבורן ולראות כמה דוגמאות אחרונות של עבודה חשובה שנעשתה בקהילה שלנו בקנה מידה של
utility קודם לכן דיברנו בקצרה על כך שלא לכל הבעיות יש צורך בכוח חישובי נוסף
ספציפית מחשוב קוונטי כדי להיפתר ביעילות אלה הבעיות שאתם כבר הכי
מכירים חשבון גלילה ברשתות חברתיות אולי משחק טטריס Doom או משחקי וידאו אחרים אנחנו בגדול מחשיבים
את אלה כבעיות קלות מצד שני יש בעיות מאוד קשות כמו למצוא גורמים ראשוניים של מספרים שלמים עצומים
וזה הבסיס של הצפנת RSA ומה שהאלגוריתם של Shor בעצם תוכנן לפתור דוגמה נוספת
היא מציאת פתרון במאגר נתונים לא ממוין זה תיאורטית ניתן לפתרון על ידי האלגוריתם הקוונטי הידוע
כאלגוריתם של Grover אבל רוב המומחים מסכימים שסוגים כאלה של אלגוריתמים ידרשו
יישום של תיקון שגיאות ואנחנו פשוט עדיין לא שם מבחינה טכנולוגית אז כשנמשיך קדימה בשיעור
הזה ובמסע החינוכי הקוונטי שלכם זכרו שאנחנו מחפשים את הנקודה המתוקה הזו איפשהו כאן באמצע
זו בעיה קשה לפיצוח אבל זה גם מה שהופך את זה לכל כך כיף דבר אחד שעוד לא דיברנו
עליו הרבה הוא תורת הסיבוכיות החישובית אחת הסיבות לכך היא שזה יכול להיות קצת מפחיד וכן
מורכב תורת הסיבוכיות החישובית היא תחום במדעי המחשב שמטרתו לסווג בעיות חישוביות
לפי כמה הן קשות יש המון מחלקות סיבוכיות שונות במחשוב קלאסי אבל הכי
בסיסיות הן אלה בעיות P אלה בעיות שניתן לפתור בזמן פולינומי בקנה מידה ככל שהבעיה
גדלה כלומר שקל לפתור אותן הסוג הבא היותר קשה של בעיה הוא בעיות NP שזה
ראשי תיבות של non-deterministic polynomial אלה בעיות שאפשר לאמת את התשובות שלהן בזמן פולינומי אבל לא
בהכרח לפתור הבא הוא NP-complete ועכשיו אנחנו נכנסים לבעיות ממש מאתגרות בלי
פתרון פולינומי ידוע כאן חיות בעיות מפורסמות כמו בעיית הסוכן הנוסע ואפילו המשחק
סודוקו עכשיו כשמחשוב קוונטי הגיע לעולם לפחות בתיאוריה אנשים השקיעו מאמץ ניכר בניסיון
להבין איזו מחלקה של בעיות הסוגים החדשים האלה של מחשבים יוכלו לפתור ביעילות מחלקה חדשה של
בעיות הומצאה שנקראת bounded error quantum polynomial או BQP בקיצור ההגדרה המדויקת שלהן היא
קצת ארוכה אבל זו מחלקת בעיות ההחלטה הניתנות לפתרון על ידי מחשב קוונטי בזמן פולינומי עם סיכוי
קטן לשגיאה יש סיכוי לשגיאה כי מדידה קוונטית היא אקראית מטבעה אבל הסתברות השגיאה
יכולה להיות קטנה באופן שרירותי עכשיו כל המחלקות האלה חיות במחלקה גדולה יותר שאנחנו קוראים לה PSPACE וכאן
אנחנו חושבים ש-BQP נמצאת ביחס לכל שאר סוגי הבעיות אבל מאוד קשה להוכיח את זה באופן חד משמעי
מתמטית תשימו לב שבעיות BQP קוונטיות לא בהכרח חופפות לבעיות NP-complete
אבל אולי בכל זאת ראיתם כמה גישות של מחשוב קוונטי שמטרתן לפתור בעיות NP-complete למה
זה ככה תפיסה מוטעית נפוצה אחת היא שאין טעם לחקור פתרונות
לבעיות כמו הסוכן הנוסע ובעיות NP-complete אחרות עבור מחשב קוונטי או כל בעיה שהוכחה
מתמטית להאצה קוונטית לא נמצאה עבורה אבל זה לא בהכרח חייב להיות המצב
למצוא הוכחה מתמטית שאלגוריתם קוונטי מהיר יותר מהמקבילה הקלאסית שלו זה נדיר Shor ו-
Grover הם שניים מתוך קומץ קטן של דוגמאות שבהן זה נעשה עד כה אבל זה בסדר למעשה מדעני
מחשב עדיין לא הצליחו אפילו להוכיח שהמחלקות P ו-NP שונות למרות שכל האינטואיציה
אומרת לנו שהן חייבות להיות וגם השוואה בין שני אלגוריתמים ואיך הם מתרחבים לרוב מסתכלת על התרחיש הגרוע ביותר
לכל אחד מהם זה בהחלט אפשרי שבפועל התרחיש הגרוע ביותר הוא לא מה שנמצא בחיים האמיתיים אז אנחנו
לא מתייאשים אנחנו מציגים במקום זאת את הרעיון של פתרונות היוריסטיים אם אתם
אנשי ניסוי אתם כבר מכירים ואוהבים את הסוגים האלה של פתרונות היוריסטיקה היא כל גישה לפתרון
בעיה שהיא פרגמטית אבל לא בהכרח אופטימלית וזה מעולה כי פתרונות לא בהכרח חייבים
להיות אופטימליים כדי להיות מאוד שימושיים לדוגמה חשבו על יישום פיננסי עדיין לא מצאנו
האצה אקספוננציאלית לרוב האלגוריתמים הפיננסיים שמחשוב קוונטי יכול לשמש עבורם עדיין אבל זה לא בהכרח משנה אנחנו לא צריכים פתרון אופטימלי
בפיננסים לפחות כי פתרון שהוא אפילו רק 1% יותר יעיל יכול להשתוות למיליארדי דולרים
של רווח אז איך אנחנו יודעים אילו מקרי שימוש ובעיות יכולים להתאים למחשוב קוונטי כרגע ובזה
אני מתכוונת שיש סיבה משמעותית להאמין שתועלת קוונטית או אפילו יתרון יכולים להימצא עכשיו או
בעתיד הקרוב יחסית אולי יותר קל קודם לציין דברים שלבעיה בהחלט לא צריך להיות
היא לא יכולה לדרוש מספר עצום של qubit אין לנו עדיין מעבדים שיש בהם אלפים עד מיליוני qubit זמינים זו אחת הסיבות העיקריות
שהאלגוריתם של Shor ודומיו כל כך רחוקים גם ה-circuit לא יכול להיות עמוק להחריד מאוד קשה לי
להגיד לכם בדיוק איזה עומק circuit לא יעבוד כי זה תלוי בכל כך הרבה גורמים אבל באופן כללי אם הניסוי
שלכם דורש עומק שלא ראיתם מושג בספרות עדיין ייתכן שזה יהיה קשה וגם
לבסוף כל סוג של אלגוריתם שאנחנו יודעים שידרוש תיקון שגיאות עדיין לא ניתן לביצוע מה שכן צריך לחפש הם ניסויים שמשתמשים
ברוב ה-qubit הזמינים בכל QPU נתון אנחנו גם מדגישים את
החשיבות של הפחתת שגיאות ודיכוי שגיאות ולבסוף צריכה להיות הרחבה ברורה ליישומים עתידיים
שיהיו חשובים לחברה ושנוכל לראות שבסופו של דבר יובילו ליתרון
קוונטי עכשיו בואו נדבר על כמה דוגמאות של מקרי שימוש שנופלים לשלוש קטגוריות עיקריות שזיהינו
כסבירות ביותר לראות תוצאות חיוביות בטווח הקרוב עד
הבינוני התחום הראשון הוא סימולציה של הטבע דיברנו על זה קודם יש
כל כך הרבה הזדמנויות למחשבים קוונטיים לשפר את המחקר שנעשה ברמה המולקולרית והאטומית
והסיבה לזה היא שהשיטות הקלאסיות הנוכחיות מוגבלות על ידי תיאורים מתמטיים שהם ביסודם לא יעילים
של מבנים אטומיים אחסון ומניפולציה של מצב קוונטי דורשים כמות אקספוננציאלית של משאבים
על מחשב קלאסי אבל אפשר לעשות את זה ביעילות על מחשב קוונטי וזה מה שהופך סימולציית חומרים
ומידול כימי לתחומי היישום המבטיחים ביותר ליתר דיוק זה יכול להוביל
להתפתחויות בלכידת פחמן דו חמצני סוללות חלופיות או המצאת תרופות חדשות כמה
אלגוריתמים שרלוונטיים במיוחד בתחום הזה הם ה-variational quantum eigen solver או vqe שמשמש
להערכת תכונות מסוימות של חומר כמו שיווי משקל או מצבי אנרגיה מינימלית דוגמה נוספת היא
סימולציה דינמית של זמן TDS האלגוריתם הזה משמש להערכת פונקציות תגובה או תכונות ספקטרליות של
חומרים ורציתי גם להזכיר שחקן חדש sample based quantum diagonalization שאנחנו חושבים שנשמע
עליו הרבה יותר בעתיד הקרוב תחום היישום הבא הוא אופטימיזציה עכשיו אופטימיזציה היא די
נפוצה בכל מקום במחשוב כמו שאתם יכולים לדמיין אז מקרי השימוש הם רבים ומגוונים
עם זאת כמה דוגמאות שאנחנו שומעים עליהן הרבה הן אופטימיזציית תיקי השקעות בפיננסים עיצוב תעשייתי וגם
הפצה ושרשרת אספקה האלגוריתם הנפוץ ביותר שכנראה תשמעו עליו בהקשר לאופטימיזציה הוא זה שכבר
כיסינו לעומק מסוים ה-quantum approximate optimization algorithm או
qaoa לבסוף תחום אחד שהיה לגביו הרבה התרגשות בשנים האחרונות הוא quantum machine learning עכשיו אני
חושב שהוגן לומר שנראה ש-qml לא הולך לקרות כמהר כמו סימולציה ככל הנראה אבל בכל זאת יש
כמה אלגוריתמים מרשימים שאנשים עובדים עליהם באופן עקבי שמתאימים לכמה מקרי שימוש מאוד
חשובים חלק ממקרי השימוש האפשריים האלה הם עיבוד שפה טבעית ניתוח תעבורת רשת ואפילו זיהוי
הונאה בעסקאות פיננסיות אלגוריתמים רלוונטיים בתחום הזה הם quantum support vector
machine רשתות נוירונים קוונטיות ורשתות quantum generative adversarial עכשיו כדי להבהיר שלוש
הקבוצות שתיארנו הן תחומי יישום רחבים כדאי גם לציין שבקהילה יש
גם תועלת לקבוצות שעובדות יחד ומתמקדות בנושא ספציפי IBM הובילה יוזמה לא מזמן
שנקראת קבוצות העבודה כדי לעזור לשותפים להיפגש וליצור סינרגיה פרודוקטיבית בארבעה תחומים
ספציפיים בריאות ומדעי החיים חומרים ו-HPC פיזיקת אנרגיה גבוהה
ואופטימיזציה הנה הקבוצות הנוכחיות שלנו והגופים המעורבים במאמצים האלה אם אתם רוצים לשמוע עוד על
מה שקבוצות העבודה עושות צירפנו ארבעה מהמאמרים הלבנים שלהם בתיאור למטה עכשיו כמו שאמרתי
אני חושב שהדבר הכי טוב לעשות בנקודה הזו בקורס הוא להשקיע זמן בחקירה של איזה סוגי בעיות אנשים עובדים עליהם בחזית
הטכנולוגיה הזו ולפתח את האינטואיציה שלנו לדעת אילו סוגי אלגוריתמים הולכים לעבוד ואיך
ליישם אותם ולפני שנתחיל אני רוצה להבהיר שהמטרה העיקרית כאן היא לא להבין כל
פרט של הניסויים הסוג הזה של ניתוח יכול להיות מאוד מאיים אפילו למומחים אם המאמר קצת
מחוץ לתחום המומחיות שלכם המטרה היא פשוט לעזור לפתח אינטואיציה לסוגי הבעיות שמחשבים
קוונטיים טובים בהם ואיך לטפל בהם ואם אתם מעוניינים בפרטים הדקים יותר וזה הצית כמה
רעיונות משלכם אני בהחלט מעודד אתכם ללכת ולקרוא את המאמרים המלאים בעצמכם מקרי השימוש הספציפיים
והמאמרים שאנחנו הולכים להעמיק בהם הם אלה קודם כל נחקור מאמר שדן
בסימולציה של דינמיקת הדרונים זה נופל בקטגוריית פיזיקת האנרגיה הגבוהה אחר כך נסתכל על בעיית
אופטימיזציה ספציפית bias field counter adiabatic quantum optimization ולבסוף נסתכל על עוד בעיית
סימולציה אבל הפעם עם מיקוד ב-mRNA מולקולה קריטית לפיתוח
תרופות וטיפולים אם אתם מכירים או לא מכירים את המאמרים האלה זה בסדר גמור אנחנו הולכים לעבור
על כולם שלושתם מאמרים חשובים שמתמודדים עם בעיות בסדר גודל משמעותי ומראים איך מחשבים
קוונטיים מתחילים לשמש כשיטה נוספת של חקירה מדעית ראשון הוא סימולציה של דינמיקת
הדרונים ואנחנו הולכים להיכנס לעומק למאמר של הקבוצה של Martin Savage מאוניברסיטת Washington בשם quantum
simulations of hadron dynamics in the schwinger model using 112
qubit אם אתם לא פיזיקאים של אנרגיות גבוהות אולי בכל זאת מוכר לכם המונח הדרון כמו ב
Large Hadron Collider או ה-LHC שהוא מאיץ החלקיקים הענק באורך 27 קילומטר בהיקף שאפשר
בזכותו סוף סוף לצפות בבוזון הִיגס עכשיו הדרון הוא חלקיק תת אטומי מורכב שמורכב מחלקיקים קטנים
אחרים שנקראים קווארקים כמה דוגמאות הן נויטרונים ופרוטונים קצת רקע ה-LHC נבנה
כדי לאפשר חקר פיזיקה בסיסית ומה קורה לחלקיקים כשהם מתנגשים באנרגיות סופר גבוהות
בצינור המעגלי הזה על ידי כך מדענים מקווים ללמוד יותר על איך היקום המוקדם נוצר
וכמו שאמרתי קודם הוא גם שימש למציאת בוזון הִיגס שהוא חלקיק חמקמק שאחראי למסה של
חלקיקים בסיסיים עכשיו באופן עקרוני האינטראקציות של החלקיקים האלה יכולות להיות
מדומות מההתחלה ועד הסוף עם מחשב קוונטי חזק מספיק אנחנו עדיין לא שם אבל נעשית התקדמות
עכשיו מודל Schwinger הוא מודל פשוט שמשמש לסימולציה של חלק מהדינמיקות האלה והוא הפך לאחד
מהמודלים הפופולריים ביותר לבחירה הפרטים של המודל לא סופר סופר חשובים כרגע אבל למי שסקרן
זה מודל שמתאר את ההתנהגות של אלקטרונים ופוזיטרונים שמקיימים אינטראקציה דרך פוטונים ב-1+1
ממדים כלומר יש ממד מרחבי אחד וזמן למודל יש הרבה דמיון לכרומודינמיקה
קוונטית שמתארת איך קווארקים והדרונים מקיימים אינטראקציה עכשיו את זה קשה מאוד לסמלץ אז מודל
Schwinger משמש לעתים קרובות כמודל צעצוע לחקירת תופעות שבעצם משותפות
לשניהם עכשיו הדרך שנתקדם עם הדוגמה הזו ועם שאר הדוגמאות שבחרתי כאן היא
לשאול את עצמנו סדרת שאלות הראשונה היא למה הייתה לנו סיבה להאמין שסימולציה של זה
על מחשב קוונטי תעבוד בכלל במקרה הזה לאלקטרונים ולפוזיטרונים במודל Schwinger יש אפקט
סינון שגורם לקורלציות בין פרמיונים רחוקים לדעוך באופן אקספוננציאלי עם המרחק וזה אומר שאין
כל כך הרבה אינטראקציות ארוכות טווח מ-qubit בצד אחד של השבב ל-qubit בצד השני של השבב
מה שאנחנו יודעים שמאוד רגיש לשגיאות אז זה ממש טוב לחומרה שיש לנו היום הבא הוא
האם הנושא הזה בכלל מעניין ובכן אני מקווה שכבר שכנעתי אתכם שכן פיזיקת אנרגיה גבוהה מאוד
מעניינת אנשים היו מוכנים להוציא מיליארדי דולרים על בניית ה-LHC ואלפי מדענים
וטכנאים ברחבי העולם הקדישו את חייהם לתחום הזה ככה זה חשוב אבל מודל
Schwinger הוא פשטני ולא מתוכנן לכסות שלושה ממדים מרחביים עם זאת הוא מודל
חשוב כי הוא עדיין מספק פרוסות שניתנות לבדיקה כיום ופישוט שימושי של תיאוריה
שלמה לבסוף איך העבודה הזו נעשתה או איזו גישה הם היו משתמשים בה אם היו רוצים להמשיך את העבודה
בניסויי סימולציה vqe היא אחת הגישות הנפוצות ביותר והשלב הראשון הוא כמעט תמיד אותו דבר
להכין את מצב היסוד במקרה הזה זה מצב הריק ובניסוי הזה הם השתמשו בגרסה חדשה של vqe שנקראת SC
adapt vqe כדי להכין גם את מצב היסוד וגם את חבילת הגל של ההדרון מעל הריק השלב הבא הוא
לתת להדרונים להתפתח או להתקדם בזמן לבסוף אנחנו צריכים לזהות את
הנצפים שאנחנו רוצים למדוד עכשיו אם השלבים האלה נשמעו לכם קצת מוכרים מלבד חלק חבילת הגל של
ההדרון זה בגלל שהשלבים האלה מאוד דומים למה שכיסינו בדוגמת ה-qaoa בפרק הקודם
בתקווה אתם מתחילים לראות דפוסים שמתגלים כאן הרכיבים הנדרשים ל-vqe מאוד דומים ל-qaoa
אנחנו מתחילים ממצב מוכר כאן מצב הריק ואז נותנים לו להתפתח בזמן עם סדרה של המילטוניאנים מוערכים
מחולקים לחתיכות ניתנות לניהול כאשר n הוא מספר החלוקות ההבדל הגדול היחיד כאן
הוא שאנחנו יוצרים את חבילת הגל של ההדרון במרכז ה-circuit שלנו לפני שמתחילים לתת לו להתפתח אז איך זה
נעשה ובכן מצב הריק הוא מצב היסוד וכבר כיסינו איך למפות את זה עכשיו הכנת חבילת הגל של
ההדרון היא קצת שונה על הריק הזה אפשר לעורר הדרון על ידי יצירת זוג פרמיון-אנטי פרמיון על
אתרים סמוכים על ידי הכנת סופרפוזיציה של הדרונים כאלה במיקומים שונים חבילת גל
שרירותית יכולה להיות מוכנה המחברים מיקמו את חבילת הגל שלהם במרכז ה-circuit כדי לצפות בהתפתחות
בלי לחרוג מגבול אבל זכרו שם המשחק כשעובדים עם QPU רועש הוא לשמור על
עומק ה-circuit ניתן לניהול כדי לעשות את זה פרוטוקול SC adapt vqe משתמש בסימטריה
והיררכיות בסקלות אורך כדי לקבוע circuit קוונטי בעומק נמוך להכנת מצב הרעיון הוא שזה
ייצור אנזץ עם מספר קטן יותר של פרמטרים ששווה ערך לעומק רדוד יותר פרטים נוספים כמובן
אפשר למצוא במאמר ממה שיש לנו זמן לכסות כאן אז תבדקו את זה עכשיו בואו נסתכל על התוצאות הניסוי הזה רץ על
מכשיר IBM Quantum Heron ויישם כמה סוגים שונים של הפחתת ומניעת שגיאות
כולל טכניקה חדשה יותר שנקראת operator decoherence renormalization וכן dynamical decoupling ו-zero noise
extrapolation ו-Pauli twirling עכשיו בואו ננסה לפרש את הנתונים הנצפה שאנחנו באמת הולכים
למדוד כדי לצפות באיך חבילת הגל מתקדמת הוא משהו שנקרא chiral condensate שזה קצת
מופשט אבל זה בעצם שלב של נוזל על של ההדרונים עכשיו אנחנו יכולים לראות את חבילת הגל ממורכזת כאן על
האתרים שיועדו להרצת הניסוי הזה כאשר הצבע מתאים ל-chiral condensate הצד
השמאלי מראה את התוצאות ללא שגיאות מהסימולטור בעוד הצד הימני מראה את התוצאות ממחשב IBM quantum
Torino באופן אידיאלי אלה היו צריכים להיות תמונות מראה אחת של השנייה בגלל סימטריה אז אפשר לראות שיש
כמה חוסרי שלמות עכשיו ציר ה-y האנכי הזה מתאים לחתיכות הזמן ש
מדדתי קודם אז למה שלא ניקח כמה חתכים אופקיים דרך צעד הזמן הראשון והאחרון של הנתונים כדי לראות
מה קורה לחבילת הגל בזמן t שווה 1 כאן בכתום שמתאים
לחתך הזה אתם יכולים לראות שה-chiral condensate צר וממוקם זה גם מתאים ממש טוב
לסימולציה שנעשתה להשוואה ב-t שווה 14 לעומת זאת הוא הרבה יותר מפוזר ופחות
ממוקם אולי ההשוואה לסימולטור לא כל כך מושלמת עכשיו אבל עדיין אפשר לראות בבירור התאמה מאוד טובה בין התיאוריה לנתונים
מה שמעודד לסיכום זו דוגמה מאוד מגניבה לסוג עבודת הסימולציה שלא בהכרח חושבים עליה בהתחלה
כשמדברים על יישום מחשבים קוונטיים אבל בפועל אפשר וזה עובד זה לא מושלם אבל לא צריך להיות מומחה
לפיזיקת חלקיקים כדי לראות שהמחשב הקוונטי מנבא בדיוק את ההתפשטות החוצה של חבילת הגל
וזה בדיוק מה שציפינו למצוא בתקווה עבודה עתידית בתחום הזה תמשיך ופיזיקאים של אנרגיות גבוהות
ימשיכו למצוא דרכים לשלב מחשוב קוונטי בזרימות העבודה שלהם המטרה היא לפתור בעיות תיאורטיות בצורה מדויקת יותר
ואת אלה שלא ניתן לפתור באופן קלאסי ולהשתמש בניסויים כדי לקבל או לדחות תיאוריות בתקווה לגלות פיזיקה
חדשה לבנות גלאים משופרים ולהוביל להבנה טובה יותר של הטבע ברמה הכי בסיסית
שלו הדוגמה הבאה שלנו מתמקדת באופטימיזציה ותהיה צלילה עמוקה למאמר בשם biased field
digitized counter adiabatic quantum optimization שנעשה על ידי חברי צוות kipu quantum מ
אוניברסיטת ארץ הבאסקים בספרד נתחיל כמו שעשינו קודם
עם סדרת הגדרות הראשונה היא counter adiabatic שהוא סוג של התפתחות שמדכא אפקטים לא-אדיאבטיים
שמערכת חווה ללא קשר למהירות התהליכים האלה זכרו את המשפט האדיאבטי מ
הפרק הקודם בדרך כלל צריך לתת למערכת להתפתח לאט מאוד אם רוצים שהיא תישאר במצב היסוד
זו בעיה גדולה כי ככל שנותנים לדברים להתפתח לאט יותר יש יותר זמן לשגיאות
לקרות counter adiabatic driving בקיצור CD שואף להילחם בזה על ידי
הוספת איברים שמנטרלים את העירורים הלא רצויים האלה הרעיון המרכזי כאן הוא לזרז את כל הניסוי
ולהפחית את עומק ה-circuit הקוונטי על ידי דיכוי עירורים שיכולים להוביל למעברים
מזויפים עכשיו בואו נדבר על מה זה bias field אלגוריתמים איטרטיביים אחרים כמו vqe לוקחים פרמטרים קלאסיים
למצבים האלה ומשתמשים באופטימייזרים קלאסיים כדי לחפש במרחב הפרמטרים הרב ממדי את הסט
שנותן ערך ציפייה מינימלי להמילטוניאן קבוע במקרה הזה הם במקום זה משנים את ההמילטוניאן בכל
פעם ונעים באופן אדיאבטי ממקרה ידוע למקרה שמעניין אותנו אבל מכיוון שאין פרמטרים קלאסיים שמועברים
ואין פונקציית גל וריאציונית איך מעדכנים את המצב ממעבר אחד של ההמילטוניאן לבא ובכן
הם מוסיפים bias field להמילטוניאן מה שהיה מצב האנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר מההרצה הקודמת הם מוסיפים איבר
בהמילטוניאן שמטה את המצב לטובת זה אז למה הניסוי הזה
מעניין ובכן קודם כל זו גישה חדשה שיכולה להיות מיושמת באופן כללי יותר לבעיות אופטימיזציה אחרות
אבל במקרה הזה הם יישמו אותה על בעיית Ising spin glass כמו שדנו קודם הרבה בעיות
אופטימיזציה קומבינטוריות אפשר לנסח מחדש כפתרון למצבי אנרגיה נמוכה של המילטוניאני Ising מודל
Ising הוא סדרה של ספינים מיקרוסקופיים מפוזרים על מערך המודל יכול לשמש לתיאור spin glass שבו
המגנוט הוא לא מסודר בעצם המומנטים המגנטיים הקטנים מכוונים באופן אקראי במערך
ולמה חשבנו שזה יעבוד ובכן כבר כיסינו איך אנחנו נלחמים בשתי בעיות טיפוסיות שנמצאות
באלגוריתמים וריאציוניים כשכיסינו את ההגדרות של המאמר אבל לסיכום האלגוריתם שהם
מציעים מזרז את ההתפתחות כדי להפחית את עומק ה-circuit ובמקביל מדכא מעברים לא-אדיאבטיים
בנוסף הוא לא מסתמך על שום שגרת אופטימיזציה קלאסית שיכולה להוביל ל-barren
plateaus ולהיתקע במינימומים מקומיים לבסוף המחברים גם מקפידים ליישר את האינטראקציות בבעיית
ההמילטוניאן עם הקישוריות של החומרה ב-QPU האמיתי מה שתמיד מאוד חשוב לבסוף איך זה עובד אז
כמו שאמרתי אין כאן אופטימייזרים קלאסיים בשימוש כמו שיש לעתים קרובות באלגוריתמים קוונטיים איטרטיביים
במקום זה על ידי הזנת הפתרון מכל איטרציה כקלט לאיטרציה הבאה אלגוריתם bias field digitized
quantum optimization משפר בהדרגה את מצב היסוד ומקרב אותו יותר ויותר ל
מצב המפותח הסופי ובשילוב עם פרוטוקולים counter adiabatic אפשר לעשות את זה אפילו עם circuit קוונטי קצר
שאמור לרוץ חלק על חומרה רועשת אז כשהניסוי בוצע המחברים בחרו להריץ את
האלגוריתם על מחשב IBM quantum בן 127 qubit Brisbane כאן המחברים הראו
את ה-ethization של אלגוריתם האופטימיזציה עבור מופע spin glass שכנים קרובים שנוצר באקראי
על יותר מ-100 qubit הם משווים תוצאות סימולציה אידיאליות מ-DCQ ו-BF-DCQ
כמו גם את התוצאה הניסיונית והם גם מראים תוצאה מפותר קלאסי שנקרא Gurobi כהשוואה עכשיו
עם רק 10 איטרציות BF-DCQ מספק שיפור דרמטי בהשוואה ל
DCQ למרות שהתוצאה הניסיונית קצת שונה מהתוצאה האידיאלית בגלל רעש הביצועים עדיין
טובים יותר מה-DCQ האידיאלי זה מראה שעדיין נעשית התקדמות מצוינת בנוגע
לאופטימיזציה קוונטית ותוצאות טובות מדווחות על יותר מ-100 qubit לאחת מהפעמים
הראשונות אחרון חביב הוא מאמר מאוד מעניין שחוקר חיזוי מבנה mRNA מהחברים שלנו ב
Moderna Pharmaceuticals והוא נקרא mRNA secondary structure prediction using utility scale quantum
computers בתור התחלה אם אתם כמוני ועדיין לא לקחתם קורס ביולוגיה כבר כמה שנים אתם יכולים לרענן את עצמכם על מה זה
mRNA שליח RNA הוא סוג של RNA שמעורב בסינתזת חלבונים הוא
בעצם קורא הוראות שניתנות על ידי DNA המבנה המשני של mRNA הוא פחות או יותר איך השרשרת מקופלת
ובעיית חיזוי המבנה המשני של RNA היא הבעיה של מציאת הקיפול היציב ביותר של הרצף
של בסיסים של נוקלאוטידים שמרכיבים DNA ו-RNA אלה הם C G U ו-A
התמונה כאן מראה כמה ממבני הקיפול הנפוצים שנמצאים ב-mRNA כל צבע מסומן כאן מראה
מבנה משני שונה אבל המאפיינים המדויקים למה מבנה אחד מועדף על
פני אחר לא מובנים היטב כל מה שאנחנו יכולים לעשות הוא להבין לאיזה מהם יש את האנרגיה החופשית הנמוכה ביותר בהשוואה ל
מצב הלא מקופל ושם מחשבים קוונטיים נכנסים לתמונה אז למה מבנים משניים של mRNA
חשובים ובכן חיזוי מדויק שלהם הוא בעצם קריטי לא רק להבנת DNA והגנים שלנו אלא גם
לתכנון טיפולים מבוססי RNA כמו החיסון לקוביד-19 יש סיבה להאמין שהגישה במאמר
הזה תעבוד כי כבר מזמן ידוע שזו בעיית אופטימיזציה קשה מאוד למחשבים
קלאסיים בגלל המספר העצום של קונפיגורציות אפשריות ולחלק מהקונפיגורציות ידוע שזו בעיה
NP-complete אבל על מחשב קוונטי אנחנו יכולים לנסח את חיזוי המבנה המשני כבעיית
אופטימיזציה בינארית משהו שאנחנו יודעים לטפל בו בנוסף כבר יש עדויות בספרות
לחיזוי RNA מדויק על מכשירים קוונטיים בקנה מידה קטן וסימולטורים קוונטיים אז השאלה הברורה היא
האם זה יעבוד על חומרה גדולה יותר הניסוי נעשה על ידי שימוש במשהו שנקרא conditional value
at risk variational quantum eigen solver שהוא שינוי של אלגוריתם ה-vqe המסורתי ו
צפוי להשיג התכנסות טובה יותר הגרף הזה מראה את התפלגות ההסתברויות של מדידת
מחרוזות הביטים שנדגמו עם האנרגיות המתאימות עבור מופע של 42
נוקלאוטידים ו-80 qubit כאן מחרוזות הביטים מסמלות זיווגים של
הנוקלאוטידים זה ממחיש שלמחרוזת הביטים בעלת האנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר יש ערך אנרגיה של מינוס 140 מה שתואם לאנרגיה הנמוכה
ביותר שנמצאה על ידי הפותר הקלאסי להשוואה אז זה מעולה וזהו המבנה המקופל האופטימלי
של שרשרת הנוקלאוטידים הזו על בסיס מחרוזת הביטים בעלת האנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר שהחומרה
מצאה ועם זה הגענו לסיום הפרק הזה עכשיו המטרה שלי כאן לא הייתה להציף אתכם
בפרטים ממאמרי מחקר שונים כמו שאמרתי פשוט רציתי לתת לכם מספיק הקשר להבין איך
עבודה בחזית התחום נראית כרגע התקווה היא שזה יגרום לגלגלים להסתובב
בראש של כולם ושעל ידי ראייה של איך אחרים ניגשים לבעיות תוכלו ליצור קשרים ותהיה לכם
הביטחון לנסות ניסויים קוונטיים חדשים שאולי לא הייתם מנסים קודם ואי אפשר לדעת אולי חלק מהם לא
יצליחו וזה בסדר בשביל זה זה מחקר קדימה זכרו שסוגי הבעיות שאנחנו
מתעניינים בהם אפשר לקבץ לפי מתודולוגיה או לפי נושא ואנחנו פירטנו את אלה שלדעתנו הם
המבטיחים ביותר בטווח הקצר זכרו מחשוב קוונטי לא טוב לכל דבר וזה באמת רק
עדות לכמה טובים נהיינו במחשוב קלאסי רק בגלל שאתם חושבים שאפשר ליישם מחשוב קוונטי
על בעיה לא אומר שזה הולך לתת תוצאות מעניינות לצערי צריך לשקול את הסקיילינג עומק
ה-circuit הוא חרב פיפיות אנחנו צריכים שהוא יהיה גדול מספיק כדי לעשות עבודה מעניינת שמחשבים
קלאסיים לא יכולים אבל כרגע בגלל הרעש בחומרה אנחנו לא יכולים לדחוף אותו לגדלים ענקיים כי הנאמנות
תפחת הכל עניין של למצוא את הנקודה המתוקה ולדעת שזו מטרה נעה אז קחו קצת זמן
בין עכשיו לפרק הבא כדי באמת לחשוב על כמה בעיות שנתקלתם בהן ואיך אולי תרצו לגשת אליהן עם מה שלמדנו
עד לנקודה הזו תהיו יצירתיים ואל תגבילו את עצמכם ואם יש לכם רעיונות גם אם אתם חושבים שהם קצת
משוגעים ספרו לי בתגובות למטה תודה שצפיתם ונתראה בפעם הבאה